[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't know if you've heard this before
but clayton kershaw is a really good
friend a high school friend with matthew
stafford the rams quarterback
and maybe stafford's playing staying in
his house this week i don't know but
clayton kershaw the dodger great kind
enough to join us boy nobody brings up
matthew stafford uh to you at all this
week i'm gonna guess right clayton first
time today dan
so your wife and kids don't bring it up
i'm the first one to bring it up today
that's right
when did you know that he was going to
be great as a quarterback
i mean basically as soon as we started
playing football you know around here in
texas we do six-man football in fourth
grade and
he was throwing the ball i mean he was
throwing the ball further than everybody
else and then actually we did track
meets in elementary school and instead
of the shot put
we did the softball throw and the
softball throw uh he just dominated that
too so he's always he's always had a
great arm and then
um he actually is pretty smart too so
figured out the whole football team
he's pretty sorry what position did you
play
so i was the center yeah of course you
were
yeah i was the center i so freshman
freshman year football was the last year
i played football and uh
yeah i was uh matthew was on the
freshman team for like four or five
games and then he was up to varsity
pretty quick but
um yeah center it was great
but you got a good arm how does your arm
compare to stafford's
well i could throw a baseball uh i
played quarterback like fourth fifth
grade and that was about as far as i
went then i started getting a little
chunkier
and uh the line was starting to be a
little more of my calling
wait so you that you're the guy that
just said uh we'll just put you on the
line
the big cat you know no i don't i don't
think of it like that i think they're
like hey you you can really remember all
the plays and
you got a little bit of athleticism but
ultimately it was hey you're a big guy
so you're gonna go play line
are you going to the super bowl
i am i'm gonna go i'm excited about it
are you a seat guy or a sweet guy
i i wasn't too picky for the super bowl
i was just like i'll just get get in the
game but i'm a seat guy this time i'm
going to be in the seats okay do you
reach out to stafford and say hey can
you hook me up
yeah i was like matthew are you busy
you know i know we text every like once
every two months but if you can get me a
few tickets
no actually uh i actually went through
the rams and bought some tickets so i'm
excited okay but when you're in the
world series do you hook up stafford to
come and watch
i don't think he would need
me to hook him up but yeah i would i
mean yeah
you know i we changed our opinion or i
think a lot of people changed our
opinion of of you and your career when
you won the world series
i don't know did you feel do you feel
different as an athlete that you finally
win
and does that change anything
yeah 100
i mean i think
no matter how well you do in your career
when you finally do what you want to do
and win the whole thing there's just for
me there was obviously a burden lifted i
mean i just felt a sense of relief to
finally get it done and
um matthew's in a little different boat
because he's been good for so long it's
just alliance you know he didn't really
have a support system around him so
this is the first year where you know
the team kind of matches up to his
talent level and um you know he's
obviously favored to win so it's uh it's
i'm excited for him it'll be really fun
to watch
but also do you think people view you
differently do you get a different sense
when
you know the media
yeah i mean probably probably media wise
you know when it ultimately comes down
to whether you won the one or you didn't
and how you succeeded in the postseason
or you didn't so i mean i think
definitely winning helped that for me
for sure but would you rather be on the
doorstep going to the playoffs going to
the world series even if you lost where
is matthew what even getting into the
playoffs for a chance to win a
championship
yeah i'll say this a thousand times you
know i'd much rather continue to have
success and then fail over and over
again to continue to get there
because that's what you play for you
know you want to be there
and failure is a part of athletics it's
a part of sports and i think it's a
great lesson i learned a lot of things
uh failing as many times as i did so um
obviously i don't recommend it i mean if
you can just win it you should just win
it but uh uh when i finally did it was
pretty special yeah but failing is a
strong word
yeah i mean at the end of the day
when you're on the dodgers and you make
the playoffs every year um the world
series is your expectation and you know
i heard i heard some guys talking about
that with the rams as well as like
um this team was built not to make the
playoffs it was built to win the super
bowl and uh you know the trades that
they made and um the first round picks
that they gave up and
that's kind of the way we work too
talking to clayton kershaw the
three-time cy young award winner uh are
you gonna wear a stafford jersey to the
game thought about that you know the the
baseball jersey is a lot more
comfortable because of the buttons in
the front you can kind of wear it as a
jacket almost um
the football dirties are a little tight
fit i might just go hoodie um but i
haven't really made up my mind that's a
good question you know what since you're
probably not going to get in your
uniform anytime soon given what's going
on in baseball why don't you just wear
your full uniform
to the state and nobody's going to think
clayton boy that guy looks like clayton
kershaw they'd never think that you
would wear your full uniform that's a
great point
yeah think about it for sure
you know have i black on there
speaking of the baseball situation how
are you updated on what is going on
yeah you know i uh
um i just listened to walker bueller
unfortunately walker is our player
so uh he uh he's kind of in all the
meetings and kind of doing the stuff and
i've kind of been that guy in the past
you know 2011 2016 when they were going
through the labor agreements i was kind
of a guy for the dodgers and i've kind
of passed the baton so now i'm pretty
pretty removed honestly from the
situation and get updates but as far as
the day-to-day i am not involved this
this time at all but you don't know what
the future the immediate future is but
how does this affect how you prepare for
this upcoming season yeah i mean we have
to continue to prepare like we're gonna
play you know and um at this point i
mean it's february 9th like there's no
way we're gonna be in spring training in
a week um
but i hope we're in spring training soon
you know so we get the season started on
time because ultimately that's the goal
so
i i'm continuing to prepare like we're
going to start on time
but each day just seems like we're
getting further and further from that
what did you keep from uh winning the
world series
what did i keep um
i think i kept i kept my jersey um
and then i don't know your your director
is gonna get mad at me but i'm gonna
move my zoom so i have the world series
trophy right there um
yeah
yeah so got a kobe bryant
wait what else do you got there be it be
a tour guide here you want to be a tour
guide yeah yeah okay so so can i don't
know how well you can can you see all
that that's kind of my yeah that's all i
allow to be put up because everything
else just feels like i'm it's just too
much so i just i just do that
okay but
i have the the kobe and the jordan
jersey are probably my two favorite
things up there i think that's pretty
that's pretty awesome nice
and then you got a basketball
uh yeah that's magic i got a magic
basketball okay
i got a john wooden basketball over
there in the top left oh now we're
showing off
now
john wooden is like my he's awesome what
he stood for just so great
i met him
oh i don't know how many years ago but i
got to visit him he lived in a small
condominium
and i did an interview with him outside
and
he realized i really knew the history of
ucla basketball and he said would you
like to come in and i'll make you a
sandwich
so here i am
yeah like
yes of course and we go in and he opens
up his scrapbooks he makes me a pimento
cheese sandwich
i don't even like pimento
but you know it's the best damn sandwich
i ever had and i just i got to open up
this scrapbook and i'm there with john
it's one of those out-of-body
experiences because i'm just a i'm a
reporter i'm just a kid reporter and i'm
going i'm i'm in john i stayed for over
two hours
and it was it was just a wonderful
experience and uh you know so i i
understand you know that yeah yeah
the dodgers had like a leadership
program like right as you're coming up
or a rookie and we got to have dinner
there was like 15 of us i got to have
dinner with john wood one night too and
it was towards the end of his life but
he uh he talked to us took the time to
like meet each one of us
just such a such an amazing man it was
awesome how well did you know kobe
i i didn't know him super well i got to
meet him twice and um
kind of the same thing just an
admiration for his work ethic honestly i
mean i think that's what um
that's what i admired most and obviously
like how much he the competitive drive
in the spirit but um
you know being in la that's what you
hear you hear kobe kobe kobe so i got to
know him just through being out there
um man special
what about jordan how did you get the
jersey
i don't even know how i got that but
i've never met mike i've i've never met
michael jordan but uh
you know to me he's to me he's the best
so i i um
yeah i never met him though
wait how do you get a jordan jersey and
you don't you're going to have a story
with that i make one of them
i didn't like chase him down in the
parking lot i don't know how i did it
but uh it was probably some type of
silent auction oh okay charity event or
something like that no
you know what
your house is quiet
we're the kids
not usually no
no we've got two we got two kids in
school right now and then one is playing
upstairs and then we got a like a two
month old so we got four now oh no yeah
we're in it yeah you caught me i got i
got four good luck
that's awesome good luck winning a world
series the easy part clayton
i'm finding that out um
thanks for joining us great to catch up
with you and uh hopefully we have
baseball at some point this year and
have fun on sunday
all right thanks dan appreciate it
that's uh clayton kershaw a uh
three-time cy young award winner that
was fun yeah paul it's kind of neat we
have clayton kershaw on the show at
least once a year at least
probably a decade now and it's
interesting to see his career develop
because he was like this early phenom
when we had him on and you talked about
his curveball and then he became kind of
that postseason problems and you talked
about that and then he gets the world
series you talked about that now we're
talking about kids and autographs we've
had
him on his entire career and we talk
about his relationship with matthew
stafford but i love that when fritzy
goes uh uh how about clayton kershaw i
said yeah
hell yeah
i said he'd probably love to talk about
matthew stafford he's not going to talk
about the you know the labor issue no i
think that was his only concern i don't
know i have no answers to when we're
starting i hope we play at some point no
i don't think it's soon that's for sure